أولاً ، دعني فقط أحصل على رد فعلك
على الأخبار وأهميتها ،
حسنًا ، شكرًا بيانا ، من الواضح أنه
يوم رائع حقًا لأنك
لا تعرف فقط الولايات المتحدة ولكن بصراحة
للعالم ، كان
الزواهري رئيس القاعدة وأثناء ذلك  تعرف كما
في الجزء السابق أنه ربما لم
يكن يتمتع بشخصية كاريزمية مثل بن لادن ، فلا
يخطئ في ذلك لأنه كان متقدمًا كان
يخطط وينظم العمليات ، لذا
فإن إخراج رئيس القاعدة يعد
نجاحًا هائلاً وأعتقد أن كل
الفضل حقًا  يذهب إلى مجتمع الاستخبارات
الذي قام للتو
بعمل رائع في العثور عليه
والقضاء عليه ،
هنا أيضًا كان من الواضح أنه كان هدفًا
رئيسيًا للولايات المتحدة
بالإضافة إلى بن لادن بعد فترة وجيزة
من الغارة الناجحة لمجمع بن لادن في
عام 2011 في الواقع تم سؤالك خلال
شهادة أمام الكونغرس أفكارك حول
المكان الذي يجب أن يُحتجز فيه الظواهري بمجرد
القبض عليه ، لذا سؤالي هو ما
يفاجئك أكثر حقيقة أن الأمر استغرق
11 عامًا أخرى للعثور عليه  هو أو أنه
تم العثور عليه في كابول أفغانستان من جميع
الأماكن.
شبكة حقاني أو طالبان
يعملون خارج باكستان ، لذا من
السهل إلى حد ما الاختباء
في بلد كبير مثل باكستان ، لقد
فوجئت أنه كان في كابول أه نعم
أعني أنها خطوة محفوفة بالمخاطر للغاية
من جانبه للانتقال من باكستان إذا  هذا هو
المكان الذي كان فيه في كابول ، لكن من الواضح
أنه شعر بالأمان الكافي مع
حماية طالبان وربما مرة أخرى من المحتمل أن يكون
حقاني الحقاني
أنه سيكون آمنًا في كابول ، من الواضح أنه ليس
هذا هو الحال